il est grand temps de refaire le logo de
la chaîne oui parce que le logo actuel est
celui qui est lié à la série odyssée sauvage
j'aime tant ce logo mais il correspond plus
vraiment à ce qui se passe en ce moment sur la
chaîne et donc pour ce faire direction un site
en ligne qui met à disposition bah quantité
de graphistes et de créateurs qui s'appelle
fiverr et fiverr sponsorise aujourd'hui la
vidéo donc écoutez c'est parti voilà à quoi
ça ressemble fiverr vous pouvez si cherchez
tout ce qui vous intéresse vidéo animation j'ai
un peu flashé sur le travail de strawberrywish
qui donc fait des portraits de femmes avec des
pommettes des pommettes saillantes et un peu
rouges allons-y qu'est ce qu'ils proposent ?
je veuxque ce soit personnifié, que ce soit un visage
que ce soit très narcissique (rire) je vous laisse
ici et puis on se retrouve plus tard voilà je
vous retrouve le 9 février je viens de recevoir
ma commande je vais découvrir ça avec vous donc
je suis très contente du résultat elle a pris en
considération tout ce que je lui avais demandé
c'est à dire de garder un visage mais d'insérer
des éléments qui montrent mon métier à savoir la
caméra et une amphore pour l'archéologie
ça c'était jusqu'à présent et maintenant
je vous laisse
découvrir cette plateforme moi ça a été très
simple à utiliser je suis très contente du
résultat je remercie encore fiverr de m'avoir
fait confiance je vous mets dans le petit i un
lien qui vous envoie directement vers la catégorie
que j'ai consultée pour faire ce logo et vers le créateur en question
je vous mets et en barre d'information d'autres liens qui vous permettront
et bien de découvrir cette plateforme
et là  on enchaîne sur le sujet du jour
qui n'est d'ailleurs pas dénué de couleur
le sujet du jour, rome le culte impérial...c'est pourpre dans les tons
Quand on dit culte impérial à Rome, on pense
généralement à l’empereur Caligula qui faisait
décoller la tête des dieux sur les statues
pour faire sculpter la sienne à la place.
C’est vraiment arrivé hein, mais bon c’est un
cas extrême, on parle quand même d’un mec qui a
nommé son cheval sénateur. Le reste du temps, le
culte impérial, ça relève quand même plus de la
stratégie politique que de la mégalomanie.
Alors je sais, il y a déjà pléthore de vidéos
sur la religion romaine. Les mythes et les dieux,
Romulus et Remus tout ça… alors on va s’épargner
les généralités. Aujourd’hui je voudrais
développer avec vous un aspect qu’on connaît moins
donc, le culte impérial. A partir des dernières
décennies avant J.-C., avec la fin du régime
républicain, les empereurs sont progressivement
adorés comme des dieux. Ils ont leurs propres
temples, leur propre clergé, on leur adresse
des prières, on sacrifie en leur honneur, etc.
Et ce culte impérial reste victime de préjugés
tenaces. Notre ami Caligula n’y est pas
totalement étranger d’ailleurs. Ajouté
à la vieille religion romaine pragmatique et
tolérante, on considère souvent qu’il l’aurait
changée en culte obligatoire. Orchestré par des
empereurs mégalomanes, il constituerait en somme
un tournant théocratique et autoritaire. On a même
très souvent écrit que le culte impérial était la
raison pour laquelle les Romains ont persécuté
les chrétiens. En bref, il aurait transformé les
gentils Romains qui observaient tranquillement
le vol des oiseaux sur le Capitole, en affreux
bourreaux fanatisés. En réalité, vous vous en
doutez, c’est un peu plus compliqué que ça.
L’historien John Scheid nous rappelle
que la religion romaine « est fondée sur le rite,
n’exige aucune croyance explicite et conforme à
une doctrine ». Cette conception très libérale
de la religion, qu’on pourrait résumer par :
"tant que tu participes, tu crois ce que tu veux»
(c’est un alexandrin)
a permis une incroyable diversité des pratiques religieuses.
En réalité, il n’y a pas une religion,
mais une multitude de religions à Rome, puisque
chaque localité ou chaque groupe social possède
ses divinités, ses génies, ses ancêtres héroïques,
et son propre calendrier liturgique. Il y a bien
des cérémonies qui réunissent un peu tout le
monde, mais ces cultes publics ne sont que
la partie émergée de l’iceberg. Dans la sphère
privée, les pratiques peuvent prendre une grande
variété de formes : sacrifices, libations,
offrandes monétaires, inscriptions ou simples
prières, en fait, on fait comme on veut.
Ajoutez à cela que l’Empire romain par ses
conquêtes a englobé des dizaines de peuples
aux traditions religieuses variées : Celtes,
Germains, Puniques, Egyptiens, Daces, Berbères,
Arabes, Grecs, etc., et vous obtenez une infinité
de croyances et de pratiques. Il y a bien
le système de l’interpretatio romana, qui
permet d’assimiler les dieux étrangers aux dieux
romains : le Melqart des Carthaginois devient
Hercule ou le Lug des Celtes devient Mercure par
exemple. Ça permet d’y voir un peu plus clair,
mais ça reste un sacré bazar
(y’a un jeu de mot)...plusieurs niveaux de lecture...
C’est donc là-dedans que débarque le culte impérial.
Et allez, encore un dieu en plus.
Mais plutôt que d’y voir de la confusion
supplémentaire, il faut le comprendre comme une
tentative audacieuse pour unifier les pratiques
religieuses. En superposant le culte de l’empereur
à toutes les autres divinités, l’Etat romain a en
fait cherché à réunir tous les peuples conquis
avec un culte commun. Une façon de leur donner
un genre de sentiment d’appartenance. C’est loin
d’être idiot, et ça a même pas trop mal marché.
Les origines du culte impérial remontent à Jules
César. Bien qu’il n’ait pas été vraiment empereur,
puisque ce titre revient à son fils adoptif Octave
qui règne sous le nom d’Auguste, César, grand
conquérant et vainqueur des guerres civiles,
a été officiellement divinisé. Celui qui disait
descendre de la déesse Vénus a été élevé au rang
de dieu par le Sénat romain moins de deux ans
après son assassinat, c’est ce qu’on appelle
l’apothéose. On lui prêtait publiquement
des qualités surnaturelles de son vivant,
et elles sont inscrites dans la loi après sa mort.
La divinisation d’un dirigeant est un phénomène
sans précédent à Rome, c’est une reconnaissance
exceptionnelle pour un personnage exceptionnel,
mais le procédé est en fait appelé à perdurer.
Puisque les prétentions divines de César de son
vivant ont été particulièrement mal vues par
l’aristocratie romaine, et ont sans doute un
peu contribué à son assassinat, son successeur
Auguste est plus prudent. Il n’est pas question
pour lui de devenir un dieu vivant. Le talent
d’Auguste, c’est qu’il fait passer l’innovation
pour une continuité. Toute la propagande impériale
est centrée sur le terme de « restauration », de
la République ou de la religion. Auguste fait
reconstruire les temples, et condamne les dérives
orientalisantes de ses anciens rivaux comme
Marc Antoine
(le mec se déguisait en pharaon).
Pourtant, c’est Auguste qui fonde et
organise ce nouveau culte, le culte impérial.
Il inaugure une tradition dans laquelle l’empereur
est un dieu en gestation, il est nimbé d’une aura
divine, qui ne se réalisera qu’après sa mort. On
ne rend officiellement pas un culte à l’empereur,
mais à son numen ou son genius, deux
éléments assez difficiles à traduire,
des éléments de sa « puissance divine » en quelque
sorte. Ça paraît bête, mais c’est une nuance qui à
son importance à Rome. Il faut toujours préserver
la fiction du respect de la tradition. C’est comme
quand Auguste dit qu’il a restauré la République
alors qu’il a tous les pouvoirs entre ses mains,
ça donne l’impression qu’il n’est pas un tyran.
Avec le culte impérial c’est pareil. Ce n’est pas
à l’empereur que vous rendez un culte, c’est
à sa partie divine… Dieu vivant ou presque,
quoi qu’il en soit, l’empereur devient
le centre d’un véritable culte d’Etat.
Et cette qualité surnaturelle se diffuse même à
l’ensemble de sa famille, la domus augusta. C’est
visible au moment des funérailles de Marcellus,
neveu d’Auguste qui aurait dû lui succéder.
L’empereur lui fait élever une statue d’or qui le
représente en dieu. Manque de bol pour Auguste,
ces deux successeurs suivants meurent aussi avant
lui. Caius et Lucius César, les fils de son ami
Agrippa qu’il avait adoptés, morts respectivement
à 18 et 23 ans, sont tous les deux divinisés. On
connaît bien cet épisode grâce à la maison
carrée de Nîmes. Le temple bâti sur le forum
de la ville est inscrit en hommage aux deux jeunes
hommes. L’inscription, faite en lettre de bronze,
a disparu, mais elle a pu être reconstituée
grâce aux trous de fixation qui laissent
deviner l’emplacement des lettres. Exactement
comme sur un autre temple du culte impérial.
qui n'est pas très loin de Lyon et donc je vous propose de partir en balade avec moi
On est à Vienne, pas en Autriche
comme pourrait le laisser suggérer ma tenue ce jour-là mais
en Isère. On est à une vingtaine de kilomètres au
sud de Lyon, au bord du Rhône. En plus du grand
théâtre romain qui accueille les concerts l’été,
il y a un temple particulièrement bien conservé.
Ici c’est un temple élevé à Auguste, associé
à la déesse Rome. Encore une fois, ce sont les
trous des crampons qui ont permis de restituer
le texte : ROMAE ET AUGUSTO CAESARI DIVI F[ILIO],
soit À Rome et à César Auguste, fils du
divin (Jules-César). Puisque le temple
est construit de son vivant, Auguste y est
révéré en tant que fils du divin Jules César,
pas en tant que dieu lui-même, vous avez compris.
Mais le temple a ensuite accueilli une deuxième
dédicace après la mort d’Auguste. Sous le
règne de l’empereur Claude, en 42, Livie,
l’épouse d’Auguste est également divinisée.
C’est l’occasion pour les habitants de Vienne
de financer une nouvelle inscription pour
l’architrave du temple. Cette fois-ci, Auguste
et Livie sont vraiment des dieux et peut-être
associés à Apollon : [APOLLINI (?) SAN]CTO ET DIVO
AUGUSTO ET DIVAE AUGUSTAE, (À Apollon ?) vénérable
et au divin Auguste et à la divine Augusta(Livie).
Bon j'espère que cette petite balade à Vienne vous a plu
on connaît aussi à Vienne par les textes un culte municipal
dédié à Germanicus, l’héritier de Tibère décédé
prématurément lui aussi (décidément). Chaque
localité peut en fait piocher dans le réservoir
de la famille impériale pour y créer un nouveau
culte et témoigner son attachement au pouvoir.
Se pose la question de la
sincérité des Romains face au culte impérial. Dans
un siècle où les dieux traditionnels passaient
déjà pour ringards, la divinisation d’un simple
mortel a de quoi tourner carrément au ridicule.
On a du mal à se dire que les riches Romains
instruits qui faisaient ériger des stèles
en hommage à la famille impériale sur l’espace
public, croyaient sincèrement à la divinité de
l’empereur. On peut quand même imaginer qu’ils
voulaient obtenir quelque chose en échange. De
l’importance, de la reconnaissance, un petit
coup de pouce de l’empereur pour accélérer
une carrière dans la fonction publique...
On connaît plusieurs cas de riches notables
de l’empire qui puisent dans leur fortune
pour témoigner leur piété, et à qui ça a
plutôt réussi. C’est le cas d’un certain [Alerte
: Nom à coucher dehors : Epameinôndas originaire
d’Acraiphia en Grèce], appelons-le François,
de Limoges, qui finance un voyage jusqu’à Rome
en l’an 37 pour aller … [gif slurp] féliciter
le nouvel empereur Caligula. C’est plus sympa
que d’envoyer une corbeille de fruits. A son
retour en Grèce, il finance des jeux toujours
en l’honneur de l’empereur et le fait associer au
culte d’Apollon dans le temple de sa ville. Bref,
il en fait des tonnes. Ce n'est pas Caligula mais
un empereur suivant, Néron, qui le récompensera
plus tard pour sa fidélité avec la charge de
grand-prêtre de la province d’Achaïe. Poste de
prestige, emploi public, salaire, notes
de frais, RTT, place de parking, bingo.
On le voit le culte impérial, au-delà d’une
pratique religieuse, pas toujours désintéressée,
c’est surtout l’occasion de faire
une belle carrière. Ces élites,
qui prennent sur elles d’offrir des sacrifices
pour l’empereur ou d’organiser des jeux,
ne cherchent en fait souvent que leur intérêt. Et
ça, les empereurs le savent très bien. Le système
est hypocrite, et alors ? Les élites des provinces
sont des intermédiaires culturels indispensables,
ce sont les relais de la romanisation, et il est
normal qu’elles en tirent un avantage. Alors,
on facilite leur parcours, leur cursus honorum,
qui peut mener ces hommes provinciaux et leurs
descendants à de plus hautes fonctions,
pourquoi pas jusqu’au Sénat de Rome.
Même les empereurs, surtout les empereurs en
fait, ne sont pas dupes de cette hypocrisie.
L’empereur Vespasien se sentant mourir en l’an
79 aurait eu un ultime mot d’esprit selon son
biographe Suétone. Il aurait dit : « Malheur !
Je crois que je deviens dieu ! » Cette moquerie
montre bien tout le crédit qu’accordent les vieux
Romains comme Vespasien à cette divinisation.
C’est une farce pour le petit peuple.
Justement, le petit peuple. Et bien parfois, le
petit peuple… il y croit à l’empereur divinisé.
Enfin, peut-être. On ne peut pas savoir ce
que pensaient les habitants de l’empire,
mais parfois on retrouve ce qu’ils écrivent. On
possède des inscriptions dans les sanctuaires,
sous forme de graffiti notamment, qui sont des
témoignages individuels de prières adressées à
l’empereur. Et puisqu’elles sont anonymes,
et pas sur la place publique, on ne peut
pas accuser leurs auteurs de faire les fayots.
C’est le cas à Combe-de-Savoie, en Savoie donc,
où des inscriptions à l’empereur ont été gravées
dans le temple du dieu local Limetus. Etant
donné qu’il n’y avait pas de temple dédié à
l’empereur à proximité, quelques habitants
sont venus à cet endroit prier l’empereur de
les aider. C’est pas bête quand on y pense,
si vos prières aux dieux immortels ne sont pas
exaucées, priez plutôt quelqu’un qui existe
vraiment et qui a tous les pouvoirs entre ses
mains. A priori c’est plus efficace. C’est le
pragmatisme romain poussé à l’extrême en fait.
Dans la partie orientale de l’empire,
les populations ont sans doute aussi cru à
la divinité de l’empereur. La divinisation ou
l’héroïsation des dirigeants était une pratique
courante pendant la période hellénistique,
les siècles qui ont précédé la conquête romaine.
En Asie Mineure et en Egypte en particulier,
le culte des dirigeants lagides et séleucides
a fourni un précédent au culte impérial romain
qui en a simplement repris les contours.
L’empereur y est souvent adoré comme un dieu
avant même sa mort et sa divinisation officielle.
En fait on le voit, il ne faut pas considérer le
culte impérial comme un élément d’un seul tenant,
il faut tenir compte des particularités locales,
et des classes sociales. Comme pour le reste des
dieux romains, on ne prie pas l’empereur de la
même façon, à Lyon, à Carthage, à Corinthe,
ou qu’on soit paysan ou sénateur. C’est
pour cette raison que beaucoup d’historiens
parlent de « cultes impériaux » au pluriel.
Il nous reste une question à aborder,
c’est celle des rapports entre le culte
impérial et le christianisme. On a souvent
dit que si les chrétiens avaient été
persécutés, c’était parce qu’ils ne
voulaient pas honorer le culte de l’empereur.
En réalité ce n’est pas vrai. La participation
au culte impérial n’est pas obligatoire.
Les juifs en étaient exemptés d’ailleurs,
les Romains avaient compris qu’ils n’accepteraient
jamais de faire un sacrifice à l’empereur.
Ce qu’on reproche aux chrétiens, c’est
en fait de se retrancher du monde,
de ne pas participer aux fêtes civiques qui
cimentent la vie collective. On leur reproche
aussi leur origine sociale la plupart du temps
modeste et leur inculture confinant souvent
à la superstition. En bref, ils rejettent
les traditions, ils font acte de rébellion.
Le christianisme, secte nouvelle et
rejetant tous les anciens dieux, sert de
bouc-émissaire lors des catastrophes comme celle
de l'incendie de Rome en 64. La plupart du temps,
la raison de ces pogroms anti-chrétiens
n’est même pas connue, comme à Lyon en 177.
Les chrétiens restent par principe suspectés de
conspiration, il y a des rumeurs d’anthropophagie,
de crimes rituels ou de débauche collective.
Mais le culte impérial n’a rien à voir là-dedans.
C’est pendant les procès intentés aux chrétiens
qu’on leur demande souvent de faire un sacrifice
à l’empereur. S’ils refusent au nom du dieu
unique, c’est bien qu’ils sont chrétiens. Le
culte à l’empereur ne sert qu’à confirmer a
posteriori qu'ils sont des ennemis de Rome.
Au IIIe siècle, la divinisation
des empereurs continue d’être votée
par le Sénat. Caracalla reçoit par
exemple officiellement l’apothéose en 217. Mais
cette reconnaissance religieuse est de plus en
plus vidée de sa substance pour n’être bientôt
plus qu’un instrument politique. Les empereurs
demandent ou pas l’apothéose pour légitimer ou
discréditer leurs prédécesseurs. Ils s’inscrivent
ainsi dans la continuité ou en rupture selon
l’air du temps. Cette utilisation politique
est renforcée par l’extrême instabilité du
pouvoir impérial au IIIe siècle. Et quand je dis
instabilité… le IIIe siècle, c’est 52 empereurs
en comptant les co-régnants et les usurpateurs !
Cinquante-deux, alors que le siècle d’avant avait
connu, en comparaison, seulement 5 empereurs en
95 ans. Avec une durée moyenne de règne de 19
ans, des adoptions en bonne et due forme par
les prédécesseurs pour entretenir la fiction
familiale, les Trajan, Hadrien ou Marc Aurèle
avaient de quoi mériter la déification. Tandis que
quand l’empereur est un obscur général de province
acclamé par ses troupes, qu’il ne règne que trois
mois, et n’arrive parfois jamais jusqu’à Rome,
le diviniser devient pratiquement absurde.
La profonde crise politique du IIIe siècle,
avec ses putschs et assassinats à répétition
a sans doute porté un coup assez dur au culte
impérial. La fiction de l’empereur divin devenait
difficile à assumer quand le pouvoir changeait de
main tous les quatre matins. D’autant qu’un
modèle concurrent dont on vient de parler,
le christianisme, fournissait au même moment une
vision plus stable avec un objectif à la clé : le
retour du Christ et le salut de notre âme.
C'est un modèle simple à comprendre
Au début du IVe siècle, c’est bien cette
vision qui triomphe dans l’empire romain.
L’autorisation de la religion chrétienne par
l’empereur Constantin, lui-même converti, sonne
le glas du culte impérial. L’empereur ne va même
plus faire semblant de prendre ses prédécesseurs
pour des dieux, puisqu’il croit intimement qu’il
n’y en a qu’un seul, le dieu unique. Les derniers
lambeaux du culte impérial tombent au IVe siècle
et le pouvoir politique s’appuie désormais
sur ce nouveau discours religieux, celui de
l’empereur au service de Dieu et du Christ.
Discours particulièrement efficace puisqu’il
a fait recette pendant plus de mille ans.
On s’arrête là pour aujourd’hui, bien-sûr si vous
avez aimé cette vidéo n'hésitez pas à la partager
et à vous abonner. Je réponds à vos questions en
commentaire également. Je remercie Lucas Pacotte
à l’écriture Fiverr pour avoir collaboré avec lachaîne.
Je vous remercie je vous embrasse et à la prochaine !
Ouais
et puis Caligula, il couchait aussi avec sa sœur…
J'ai quand-même fait un exposé là-dessus, je me souviens de rien ! rires
Oui mais c'était y'a 10 ans !